Welcome back to Portainer in production.
In this episode, we're gonna take a look
at continuous deployment with Portainer
and the GitOps Parent. Let's have some fun.
Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. I'm
your host, David Flanagan,
although you probably know me from across the
Internet as Rawkode.
Today, we continue on with our Portainer in
production course.
Again, I'd kindly like to thank Neil and
the team at Portainer for sponsoring my time
to put this course together.
Thank you.
Today, we're gonna take a look at continuous
deployment with Portainer
using a git repository.
Coming from the Kubernetes ecosystem, we call this
GitOps,
where we store the deployment artifacts or manifest
in a Git repository
so that we can see how they evolve
over time
and that every change to our system is
versioned
and auditable.
If you're not deploying to Kubernetes,
GitOps has been a little bit more difficult.
It may be that you require
a configuration management tool, like SaltStack, to monitor
a Git repository
and run your deployment state.
But there actually is an easier way.
Portainer has a concept called stacks.
Now these stacks can just be YAML that
you write into the Portainer web interface,
and that will work just well.
But Portainer has another feature
where it can
clone a git repository
and keep it in sync
and deploy your stacks from there,
giving us git ops in environments that aren't
Kubernetes.
And as a recap, Portainer supports not just
Kubernetes
and not just Docker,
but Docker Swarm and Nobat too.
So let's take a look at how we
can use the get repository source for a
PortainerStack
to get continuous delivery in an environment that
isn't Kubernetes.
Let's have some fun.
Okay. So where are we starting from today?
Well, in our repository
available at github.com/rawcodeacademy/retainer-in-production,
there is a directory
called GitOps.
Inside this folder, we have a Docker Compose
file.
Docker Compose is still a fantastic tool.
When it comes to local development, working with
multiple services that need databases,
caches, queues,
there's no better way to develop than Compose.
So we're gonna use that format today. I'm
going to iterate locally on an EdgeDB deployment.
Well, I don't need to iterate. It's already
done. However, we'll make a change to show
the entire process.
So this composed file has EdgeDB configured as
a service with a little bit of configuration
that it needs to just work.
We're going to assume that we're working on
this. So we're going to run Docker Compose
up.
Now it takes just a few seconds,
but we will get a web interface
that allows us to interact
with our EdgeDB deployment.
Now it doesn't matter if you're not familiar
with EdgeDB.
It's just a relatively new database written in
Python
that is graph first with a rather interesting
query language that allows you to select data
across
all the different types within the system.
If we go to our web browser,
we can go to 5656,
where we can log in with
EdgeDB and Portainer.
It allows us to select the database.
We can open a REPL if we want.
We can browse the schema.
So you can see the language here for
defining our tables in EdgeDB
as a type system where we have a
type of a blog post with a required
property
of ID,
content, and title.
We can also browse the data where at
the moment we have nothing, but we could
say hello for the content
with the title being
title.
Very imaginative.
From here, we can review and commit our
changes,
and that's all you need to know about
this local stack.
So we're in a position where our Docker
Compose does what we want it to do.
We've tested the service does what we want
that to do.
How do we get this to production?
We don't just want to run it in
our local machine.
Now production doesn't always have to mean a
series of distributed topology aware Kubernetes clusters with
advanced scheduling and bin packing with remote secrets
management and blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah.
A lot of the time, we're all building
niche applications
for a small subset of users,
usually available internally,
sometimes publicly,
and we just need a container to run
on a machine.
So running Portainer with Docker on a machine
gives you an immediate value add. It simplifies
your life from Kubernetes.
Now, of course, Portainer works really well with
Kubernetes, and we're gonna do a couple more
videos on that in due course. But today,
we wanna take the use case that I
hope resonates with the majority of people watching
this video.
How do I run containers with continuous delivery
and get ups on one machine
with ease?
So let's take a look.
The first thing we do is go to
Portainer.
If you watched the first video, you'll know
that this is available for me on p.Rawkode.academy,
where I have a single EC two instance
running at a Docker engine with Portainer on
top.
We can click on that environment and go
to stacks.
As you'll see at the moment, we have
no stacks.
So let's click on add stack and add
our stack.
Now I'm going to call this stack EdgeDB.
Now we could use the web editor and
paste our compose YAML here. We could upload
it from our machine or even use a
custom template,
but today I wanna focus on the GitOps
model and continuous delivery.
From here, you can add your repository URL.
Mine is on GitHub at github.com/rockhodeacademy/containerinproduction.
My reference is ref head main
and my Docker Compose file is in the
GitOps
GitOps directory at DockerCompose.YAML.
Now we're going to turn on continuous delivery
by enabling the automatic update setting.
We're gonna start with the simplest solution, which
is to turn on polling at one minute.
We can force it to pull the latest
image and force a redeployment.
However, we won't need that last option today.
If we need to provide any environment variables,
perhaps to configure a new secret in production
as opposed to what we use in dev,
we can do so from here.
Now we click deploy the stack.
Sometimes it just feels too easy.
So let's click on our stack and scroll
down.
We're able to modify the fetch interval if
we're not deploying as frequently as we want,
although I am going to use one minute
today so we can actually make a change
to this repository.
It may make more sense for you to
use fifteen minutes or even an hour, or
perhaps you only deploy once per day.
That choice is up to you.
Now if we scroll down to the bottom,
we'll see our containers. We can see now
that our EdgeDB stack is spinning up.
And if we click on that, we get
all the benefits that Portainer brings, which is
the ability
to understand and visualize what is happening in
our environment.
Here, we have the ability to kill, restart,
pause, and remove the container.
We can see that our container has been
running for one minute,
and this little green heart means that things
are healthy.
If we scroll down a bit more,
we can see the output from the logs,
and then we see the configuration in more
detail.
From here, we can see that the ports
are configured as we expected to the same
as our development environment setup on ports five
six five six.
So scrolling through all of this, we have
a degree of confidence
that our application is running.
So we can confirm this works
by changing the URL
to port five six five six slash login.
From here, we get the Edge DB login
screen, which means our deployment was successful.
So let's make a change to our stack
and see it continuously
rolled out in a GetOps fashion by Portainer.
We can pop open our Docker Compose file,
and let's say we're going to add one
more service.
We'll add an image of NGINX latest,
and we'll map some ports.
Now we're not gonna make this available on
port 80 because we have some TLS stuff
running for cert bot,
but we can make it available on five
six five seven,
and we'll redirect it to port 80 within
the NGINX container.
Now this is a contrived change to our
Docker Compose file adding an arbitrary NGINX,
but your applications will be your services that
you change.
We can now go over to our terminal
where we add
our Docker Compose dot YAML change.
From here, we do a commit and say
feature add engine x.
We now do a git push,
and in one minute's time or less,
we should see Portainer
pick up the changes to our stack and
add the second container.
If we go back to our Portainer screen
and to our stack
and click in on EdgeDB,
and around,
hopefully,
thirty seconds time, we will see a new
container added to this list.
Voila. We have our second container.
And of course, we can confirm one more
time by changing 56
to 5657,
and we have our NGINX.
So Portainer makes it very easy
to pull the GET repository
for your Docker Compose dot YAML and make
all the changes
in a production like fashion,
which is pretty neat.
Okay. Let's take a look at one more
thing.
When we set up a stack, we set
the polling to be an interval.
Now I set it for one minute,
and I sat here awkwardly waiting for the
refresh to show you the NGINX container.
Now depending on your deployment velocity
and depending on what your project even is,
you could be deploying
four times an hour, four times a day,
or four times a year.
The polling may not be that effective,
and instead you may wish just to have
GitHub send a webhook to your Portainer instance
every time there's a change.
And Portainer makes this pretty pretty,
and Portainer makes this simple.
So let's make
a final adjustment,
a final final adjustment
to our stack.
We go into EdgeDB,
and we're going to switch to webhook.
We're going to copy this link
and click save.
So let's add the webhook to GitHub.
We go to our repository, which in this
case is Rawkode Academy slash Portainer in production.
We go to settings and webhooks.
From here, we can say add,
drop in the URL,
and say we only want the push event.
We click add,
GitHub sends a test ping, which if we
click on here,
we'll see it's a green tick. This means
our webhook was successfully configured.
We'll pop back over here and list the
containers for our stack.
So let's add one more service to our
stack.
We're going to copy nginx,
and we'll call it as HTTP T, and
we're going to run HTTP
T image.
And we won't bother exposing this to the
Internet.
Now we'll jump over to a terminal
where we can do an add, commit,
and a push.
Now if we pop back over to Portainer,
right before our eyes, we see one more
container added to our stack.
So that is get ups
with Docker engine and Portainer with Docker Compose.
It's a pretty impressive setup,
which will work well for the majority of
projects
where you just need a few containers running
on a Linux machine.
You can configure it to update your stacks
with pooling or via webhooks,
and you've seen just how easy both approaches
are.
So go check it out. Download Portainer. Remember,
the business edition is free for less than
five nodes. And if you've got less than
five nodes, this GitOps model with Docker Compose
is probably exactly what you need for production.
So
we'll have some fun.
See you next time.